everything you think that's me every
little thing you think that me every
little thing that's just feeding your
greed oh I bear that she besides Audi
hey everybody this is just a quick intro
before we dive into the podcast and
recording this in a hotel room in
Portland Oregon but what you're about to
hear actually occurred in Portland Maine
we've gone from Portland - Portland
within the last week or so and we're
having a blast on the less is now tour
we're getting ready to hit a bunch of
new cities as well this week this Friday
we are going to announce the second leg
of the less is now tour so make sure
you're on our email list over at the
minimalists comm and you can check out
all those dates real quick we're headed
over to Toronto Ottawa Montreal
Vancouver Calgary Edmonton so we're
we're doing the whole Canada stretch
there at the end of the summer and from
there we're headed over to Philadelphia
Manhattan Brooklyn it's two stops in New
York City Salt Lake City Denver Phoenix
Austin Dallas Houston Nashville
Washington DC atlanta Tampa Detroit and
Milwaukee
we're headed to 40 cities total were
actually we just finished up an event
last night in Portland Oregon but from
there we're headed over to Grand Rapids
Chicago Madison Minneapolis San Diego
Los Angeles San Francisco Indianapolis
Cincinnati Columbus and Cleveland so
we're headed to a bunch of cities a city
near you you can get tickets while they
last while they're still available over
at les is now calm all right I hope you
enjoy this live version of the Midwest
podcast and a Portland Maine stay tuned
after the show for some comments and
tips from our listeners hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
John
fulfills Millburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to a live version of
the minimus podcast we're here here in
Portland Maine on Easter Sunday thank
you for being here hello Portland and we
have some folks getting ready to ask
some questions here Ryan and I brought
some answers you got you did you bring
the answers I thought you brought the
answers John alright well we'll wing it
but here we go go ahead give us your
name and let us know what your question
is okay my name is Annie thank you guys
for coming to Portland Maine thank you
guys are here thank you
I have a question I have two kids a
seven-year-old and a four-year-old and
they both have so much stuff and I don't
know how to not only just organize it
I've gone via beyond how to organize it
but how to minimalize the stuff in their
life without doing it for them since it
mean it's definitely a lot of their
stuff really provides value for them so
I don't know if you can talk a little
bit about about that Ryan you don't have
kids so what should you do I got some
great advice I love giving out advice
when I don't have kids it's really easy
right I'm just going to I'm going to
like tweeze out some stuff from other
minimalist parents I know
Joshua Becker if for anyone who hasn't
read clutter-free with kids it's a great
book about this topic exactly but the
one thing he says in that book that
really stands out to me is that he says
you know our kids are watching us and I
think that that is really where you know
they're going to pick up their habits
from and I think again not having any
kids that make sense
but no but but you know I think that I
think that is true though I know that I
I still watch my parents in fact I was
talking to my mother earlier today and I
was you know trying to explain to her
how all of us kids look up to her and if
she could be happy then that's going to
make us happy and I'm not going to go
into depth with that private
conversation but but it's true I still
do that say at 35 years old almost said
30 I don't even know why 30 at heart but
you know the other thing too as a parent
you get to set boundaries for your kids
you don't want to make them ascetics
like you don't want to deprive them
minimalism is not about deprivation but
you certainly get to set boundaries I
had a it was actually someone at our
event I want to say was Pittsburgh just
a few nights ago and they came up and
they were talking about how they had
this toy chest from when they were a kid
it was like the sentimental item that
they had they loved it and when she was
growing up they could fill only that toy
chest and I was dead so they get all the
to it but as soon as that lick couldn't
close they had to add the data to get
rid of something and she's passed this
down on to her kids and now this is her
kids rule so I don't know what
boundaries would work for you know you
and your family I don't know if you have
a partner or not but certainly you need
to get everyone on board first but I
thought that was a really good idea and
I think he gets at other boundaries like
that that would help at least cut down
on on the clutter I'm sure I'm sure you
get a lot of gifts given to you - well
my board advantage is a how many so how
much stuff do they have a lot of stuff
and it sounds it's not to be like you're
going to hear from from your tone it's
it can be a bit overwhelming well I
don't know where it all comes from I
just like up here's it there's so many
Legos and blocks and drawings so many
drawings at all and I like your when
you're talking about your mom boxing up
your first grade and your second grade I
I am kind of that mom I have I don't
think I've ever thrown away any of their
stuff be
I don't know what they will want to then
see in the future so maybe that's kind
of a thing too but yes the first
question I would ask you to ask yourself
or just a question I would ask you would
be why do they have so much stuff and
and right now that's not really clear
but that why is is really important
because we tend to have so much stuff
because as Ryan said when he was given a
talk earlier that's what we're supposed
to do or you know we're supposed to even
you know the average kid in this country
has 238 toys we'll plays with twelve
daily and so when you realize that the
math just doesn't add up it's going to
take you an entire month to play with
all your toys and then all by the way
you realize that a month goes by and
what percentage of those toys haven't
been played with at all and so I would I
would find some strategies that work for
you Ryan mentioned a few but there are a
few rules that you can set up and rules
that I've set up that have worked well
for me
the first one that you could you can try
when you're trying to if you're trying
to pare down and figure out what are the
toys they're playing with or as adults
we to say what adds value right by the
way we have a drinking game on the
podcast no player one shot adds value
but but what are they playing with what
toys add value to them right and what
you could do is you can you can set up a
couple different boxes and you have one
box with the toy you forcing them and I
say that you know as nice as I can but
basically we have to force our kids by
telling them and showing them what to do
but you can put the toys here's the box
after you're done playing with it and
then here's the other box or or trunk or
crate or whatever has the other toys
that have not been played with and over
the course of time call it a week call
it a month you can show them you know
you haven't played with any of these
toys over over that time period also
when you're bringing new toys in or
they're bringing new toys in because
you're saying I don't know how it shows
up you're I totally get I understand but
for good news the toys don't just
manifest they'd be a lot cheaper if they
did things like they do though but I
know it does seem that way being and
then it becomes overwhelming and it's
hard to deal with but as new toys as
they want new toys basically the
question is always that I asked Ella's
I mean in she's 3 so she doesn't totally
get it yet but I asked her how are we
going to afford it and and that at least
gets her thinking about the like what
does that mean
and when I say afford it I don't just
mean the price tag right because she
doesn't understand currency yeah but I
say how are we going to afford the space
that it takes up where are you going to
put that and she doesn't have answers to
all of these questions yet but it's
sparking the idea of oh yeah anytime I
want something Josh is going to start
asking me all of these questions right
and I think I think those questions are
really important because it does create
a dialogue and it's not easy it's
certainly not easy for me to talk to
Ella she's three I'm trying to you know
I came to say we're minimalist and III
told her this about six months ago and
she said what's a minimal lalala and and
that's a difficult conversation to have
with a three-year-old I found out
because you know I've got my little
stock phrase pants or right I'm like
minimalism is the thing that gets us
past with and the problem is she doesn't
understand what a homonym is and so then
I'm like digressing to explain hominin
and currency and it just it doesn't work
and so what I found is that I will ask
her questions and that's the best way
for me to have a conversation with her
there are other rules that you can set
up as well when something comes in you
can have the the one in one out rule
I mean it's you're overwhelmed with
stuff it could be 1 in 10 out I also
have a donation box set up at the front
of the house and and we with Ella we've
developed the habit not by telling her
she needs to donate anything we don't
tell her that what we do is we show her
every time
we put something in the donation box or
we'll ask her to put our thing in the
donation box I'm no longer wearing this
shirt Ella would you please go put this
in a donation box so that on the 1st of
the month we can take it over to the
donation warehouse and let someone else
use that thing and then eventually she
caught on after I said hey can I donate
this toy so some other kid can use it I
remember the first time she said it I
was like just so proud of that and she's
taking it a bit far now she some kind of
sleigh tries to donate the broccoli
proper plate but I think if he set up
some of those rules in some of those
habits it's like a dial when you're
turning the volume up or down on
something I wouldn't try to make a
draconian we're going to get rid of half
of your toys today now it's really about
establishing those new habits thank you
I'm going to add one thing about the
pictures because there's another parent
who that is really what I do I just deal
other parents advice and pass it on I
appreciate this up so she was a curator
of parental it exactly but no she was
telling me how when her five year old
will come home with like a piece of art
that they've done they are like a
drawing and they're like oh can we put
this on the fridge and she's like you
know first off I hate telling my kids no
so like I will find ways to tell them
yes as much as possible and she's like
yeah of course we can go put that on the
fridge so then the walk over and like
the fridge is already covered in
pictures so she'll say okay which one do
you want to get rid of now and so she
will pick her least favorite one she
puts it in the trash then she brings her
picture over and then they put that new
one up on the fridge so I think again
they're just different ways that you can
kind of instill that into your kids I'll
add on top of that now
I [ __ ] hate refrigerator magnet
and and so but we have one we have one
refrigerator magnet because it's not
just about me right it's about we but in
order for them to appreciate I mean Bex
knows my partner and knows that that
yeah I don't want stuff on the fridge
but I also know that elegance tremendous
value from displaying it and I'm also
not trying to deprive her so I respect
and appreciate that and so whenever she
brings something home she wants to
display on the fridge she knows she has
to make that choice where it's not she
has to choose which one she knows
there's one thing up there and that has
to go if she wants the new thing to go
up on the fridge so that's one of the
rules I have and I'm going to thank you
thank you thank you touch so they should
be impersonal how's it going guys
howdy Goodman I'm good my name is Jake
I'm from Southern Maine because I got a
kind of a weird question so what do you
do at Christmastime are like birthdays
when people want to get you stuff how do
you get them on board yeah you want to
go first I'll go first go for it um no I
think when it comes to Christmas and
birthdays so what is this is April
physical in April yes like now is the
time to start talking to your friends
and family about Christmas it's not in
October or November when they've already
probably bought a bunch of Christmas
presents it's it's setting that
expectation upfront and it's going back
to that philosophy that that that parent
was talking about about not you know
being able to say yes as much as
possible so it's not you go to your
friends and you're like bah humbug I
don't want to celebrate Christmas
anymore I'm a minimalist you know
instead it's more about going to them
and saying you know hey I am trying to
keep my life as clutter-free as possible
and I know that you love me and I know
that you want me to be happy so I know
that you're going to support me on this
and at Christmas time I would love to
exchange some gifts with you but let's
try something different this year
let's do experiences or let's just do
consumables Oh
or I got to replace my refrigerator give
me some Best Buy gift cards like
whatever it may be but start setting
that expectation now and keep
reiterating it aren't you because I
don't know I can't wait to see what
experience you're going to get me right
and keep playing and you plant that seed
you keep growing it so by the time it
gets to Christmas you've already yours
people are starting to get yourself but
it cuts down dramatically because I have
four crock pots from Christmas I'm like
what do I even do do you you like start
a catering business I'm not a good cook
believing you look like that yeah my
wedding I had three toasters yeah and I
don't eat bread and and I mean that is
sort of like a metaphor for consumerism
right there right I mean consumerism is
letting corporations dictate your values
instead of you determining what your
values are and we've been publishing
this short animated series called
simples was anyone here seen as all
there's like a four-part video series
and it's animated
they're really short but a lot of people
been sharing it around because they're
these like little pity videos that that
have you know a little a little moral or
like a little fable basically but the
fourth one the final one in the series
is about love not being a transaction
and I think we we all think it confused
right we we're told that one of our love
languages is gift-giving I think that's
like saying that Pig Latin is a Romance
language
I think the truth is that that we all
that gift-giving is in the love language
contribution is the love language the
love language and we want to figure out
what's the best way that we can
contribute to the people in our lives
sometimes that can be through a physical
item and because of that I try to avoid
obligatory gift-giving days
well it's December 25th here I got you
this pair of boots even though you
needed them in October well I didn't
mean that deprived you for two months
for these boots if I really wanted to
get them for you it also doesn't mean I
love you it means I think you know Ryan
I got you these concert tickets and
today is April 16th well that's a bad
example cause it's a holiday today
today is April 17th I got you I got you
these concert tickets and he might be
like why'd you get them for me well
because I thought you'd find value in it
right what is today's some sort of weird
holiday or this is sweetest day because
Ryan and I get stuff for each other all
the time on sweetest day no so what I
will do is I'll give just because it's
any day because that's a better time you
don't feel the obligation so that
threshold the sort of barrier for the
burden of proof is way lower and so I'll
still give gifts on holidays but as Ryan
said I will I will gift experiences or
consumables and I will I'll go out of my
way all other days of the year to make
sure I'm giving you the right kind of
gift as well presence is the best
present awesome thank you very much
nice thank you man
howdy are here three people here are
here in line right now we will go in
depth with their answers and after them
if we can get like at least five people
will do five people to line up for the
lightning round where you can ask like a
rapid-fire question a Ryan and I will
try to give you a less than hundred and
forty character response and we've been
battling back and forth the last few
nights and we're tied up right now I
believe so you in Portland Maine can be
the tiebreaker of us winning the I like
to think it was a rap battle without
rapping so that's what we're going how D
which makes hi I'm Lea sorry I'm a
little nervous and I used to a
microphone nervous - it's okay so I'm
from New York and I'm in fear Oh
last July because I actually kind of
took your words to heart
from your books and left my job which
sounded crazy to a lot of people I know
except my family they were really
supportive of it
congratulations yeah it was awesome so I
left my crazy job 60 hours a week I
traveled six months new year it was
awful I'm sorry former employer bosses
who might be listening I was really
unhappy and that's okay doesn't mean you
know it's necessarily you know battery
you know Java just in the line with the
person you wanted to be exactly so I
convinced my partner that we were going
to move here and we did and what what
about
Portlander year it's an awesome town by
the way that's why it's a small account
of our whole tour we just really wanted
to make it back because last time we
came here in 2014 it was it was killer
I had a three-day weekend three years
ago and I was like where can I go on a
really I didn't drive at the time so
like where can I go without a car so I
took the train here for three days I was
totally alone by myself and I came here
and I'm not kidding the person my tour
guide on the boat here like doing the
mail run was like hey I'll show you
around want to come to a barbecue and I
was like I'll open it please so that's
why Portland Maine is awesome because
I'm flossing yeah that person's now one
of my closest friends and really happy
to live here so that's how I ended up
here but the cost of living is a lot
lower it also and being on that journey
of like leaving the job it was what's
next which brings up my question to you
which is when you're on that path of
figuring out what you're passionate
about and it comes with its own
stumbling blocks is like okay I'm going
to try this out or that out I kind of
wondered and this is the gap in your
story for me is like how did you manage
like trying out some things like Josh
how did you figure out you're going to
say like I'm a really a writer and like
owning that how did you figure out like
beyond starting your blog and writing
your words and just getting out there
and sharing your words like this is who
I am and owning that identity and
feeling confident stepping out there
with it
I think it's easier in retrospect ago to
sort of look back and say here's the
narrative overlay of my life you're
absolutely right but I can tell you like
we were just having a conversation today
before before this event where we're
filming some stuff right now have any of
you seen our documentary called
minimalism look at that
look at that well you all can sing this
handsome gentleman over here the Italian
stallion Matthew Bella and he he made
this documentary with us and when I say
with us I mean he pretty much made it
and he's just such a talented filmmaker
but we spent so much time on the road
and we had no idea really where we were
going with it exactly in fact this is
our fourth event on the lessons now tour
and we've we recorded all four of them
and we're not really sure what we're
going to do with it and I say all that
to say I like to turn the noun into a
verb you ask me how did I know to say I
was a writer I didn't and I still don't
and the truth is I'm really passionate
about writing and I'm not passionate
about being a writer I'm passionate
about the actual activity and I know
with Matt and we also have Conrad over
you he's under you're filming as well
let's give him a round of applause
Konrad is a crazy talented filmmaker and
we are just so lucky to have both these
these guys on the road with us for this
but what what I would have learned is
that it's about doing these actions and
you know what that documentary is 79
minutes long but we had over 2,000 hours
worth of footage so there's a thousand
999 hours out there somewhere that never
got used and it was much more about
doing the work and then once you do it
you'll figure out like there are pieces
that work but most of it doesn't work
because the key then is drudging through
the drudgery and being willing to get to
the other side of it and and they may
seem like failures at the time and by
definition they are but all of my
successes are birthed out of million
little failures yeah I would say don't
don't stress yourself out too much about
finding out what you're passionate what
your passion is because I know you
probably want to like change the world
we got it yeah
but you know I would say you know and
maybe you're at this point but if the
only person that you change your entire
life is yourself like that's okay and
you know maybe right now your purpose is
not you but any of you like maybe your
purpose is to like pay off your debt or
maybe it's to take care of your sick
grandmother or whatever it may be like
it's okay to have this small purposes I
think when it comes to passion like for
me I'm passionate about a lot of things
I love to snowboard I love to longboard
pretty much anything with Bourdon and I
like to do
except waterboarding but but uh tried it
none of your business
but what I'm saying is is that those
aren't changing the world I mean and
this is great and this is my passion
don't get me wrong but when when I can
not be on tour and get to the top of the
mountain and go to then you know go down
some awesome runs like that makes me
feel so good
makes me feel almost as good as like
this makes me feel but but my point is
is that you don't you're not born to do
one thing there's a one thing out there
that you were born to do I mean really
the only way you can you know figure out
what your passions are is by trying out
some stuff and you can't try it all out
at once it sound like I did all those
things once like right now I have a
snowboard I got a mountain bike
longboard and I use all those things and
you know what I live in Missoula Montana
which by the way is anyone here been to
Missoula Montana is Portland it's
because Portland reminds me of Missoula
a little bit this is the Missoula remind
you of Portland oh now it's like it's
like a very big small town yeah and what
it feels like I was just I was just
wondering but I live in Missoula Montana
I want to fly-fish like I really want to
go for I really want to pick up that
hobby but like I already have so many
different passions in my life oh I'm not
gonna I'm not going to do that because I
know how hard it is for me during winter
to get up in the mountain how hard is
for me to get up in the mountains with
my mountain bike and longboards pretty
easy because like I can just kind of
skate around go to work and stuff but
but I know that if I picked up that
fly-fishing hobby that I wouldn't even
have time to turn it into a passion now
maybe one day I'm going to wake up and
I'm like sixty years old and I'm like
man my back's really hurtin I don't
think I'm going to be able to snowboard
this season but actually I hope that
isn't that my partner Mariah her dad's
six years old most still like beat me
down the hill sometimes so hopefully I'm
not doing that but I might and then I
might be like you know it's time to pick
up some fly-fishing
so don't don't stress yourself out about
it too much I would just pick things
that you are interested in and go out
and do it and you might do it really
this isn't that fun maybe I'm not
passionate about it but if you really
haven't committed to it and stuck to it
Drudge through that drudgery then you
really will never know if you were
passionate about it or not awesome thank
you because you just get stuck in a job
and your that's my identity I was that
person that job title with me and when
you leave that you start something else
and it's it's wonderful to have a fresh
slate that's a gift and I don't take
that for granted but to have that and
then be like oh I can be whatever it's
hard to say what you know and to your
point is exploring so it's really
helpful thank you you're welcome
you've got like ten ideas you're like
these are the ten ways I could change
the world like if you can't pick one we
just put them in a hat like pull one out
and like just start you know I mean I
know that's such a simple piece of
advice but that's what we do and if you
have no ideas then figure out what
pisses you off and a lot of the times
that will point you in the right
direction great thank you
[Music]
all right I don't think anyone lining up
to a lightening round so this we're
going to be somebody a quick podcast
yeah you can spend more time on our
question
yes all right oh there they go there
they are hello fellas howdy my name is
Sean and here's my your tires okay we
I'm sorry we have two Sean's with us
here and it's they're both are you from
Ohio I know no I'm like you rescind my
offer I spell it sa jwn now does he
spell it that way yeah yeah that's the
only correct way to solid yeah that's
what I think so my nickname is dubs they
call me dubs because W is this sort of a
rare way to spell it apparently around
some parts so anyway here's my scenario
a couple of years ago I moved in I live
about four hours north of here there is
a north of here Wow and it's a little
town called caribou and two years ago
yeah two years ago I moved into it a
little 95 square foot camper that I
parked on my parents land and in order
to do that I had to get rid of a lot of
stuff obviously I'm lucky that I have
some storage options so I have boxes of
stuff that's that's still waiting to be
paired down but I've gone through this
process of paring down my stuff like
systematically and getting less and less
and less and it's been it's been great
it's been very successful and I've
enjoyed the process and the results but
the problem is that I'm hitting this
wall now because I get to my hobbies
that I'm passionate about and I've got
these two in particular so I love
creating music and that necessitates I
have got guitars I've got drums if you
have microphones you have mixers you
know got wires and but that music
absolutely adds value to my life it's my
mental health right so that's so I
stopped there and I said I'm not getting
rid of that stuff because that's
important to me and then I have
electronics I love tinkering with
electronics and I built circuits and and
I saw I've got microchips and I've got
more wires a lot of wires in my life and
obviously the power supplies and boxes
of things and it's like I'm going to
need that someday to build a circuit and
but that adds value to my life because
I've been able to build my own like home
automation for my camper
I have a garden that's robotically
controlled and I have it all on my phone
and it's like ohms it took me so thank
you thank you
and I'm passionate about combining this
organic lifestyle with this technology
lifestyle and combining these two you
and I I've taken a page of your book and
I've been blogging about all of this
stuff and it's going really well but
again the same thing that boxes of power
supplies and boxes of this and it's like
I can't get rid of that so I'm kind of
hitting this wall and I'm telling myself
that that's the fad value to my life so
so I can't get rid of it but I'm also a
recovering alcoholic who's very skilled
at lying to himself yeah so so I'm
getting that walnut let me let me sort
of a bit of a conversation here what why
do you want to get rid of it
well I I guess I'm getting at a point
where I think I don't need as much of it
as I as I have so I say like when I just
said that I was finding myself saying I
have mixers plural I have microphones
plural yes like maybe I don't need as
many like it can pair that down and I've
done some of that but I hit the wall and
I think I can't get rid of that because
I need because it adds value but how do
I break through and say I know I'm lying
to myself I don't need as much as I have
yeah so so I believe in creative
limitations and I think it's it's a
spectrum or really I look at as a
pendulum right so there you could be one
at one side where you have multiple
mixer mixers mixing boards that you're
not I mean you should see our our really
fancy podcast studio it's a little
machine about the size of this
microphone and two microphones right
it's a zoom h6 and that's pretty much in
some power cord that plugs into the wall
and that's our our setup and we can
pretty much take that anywhere
and what I've learned with these
creative limitations is sometimes it
actually brings out the creativity in
you by by limiting what you have I'll
give you a few examples here so with
respect to writing because that's what
I'm really passionate about I used to
have all these rules set up for me I
needed 15 different things before I ever
started writing so through I spent most
of my 20s as an aspiring writer which
means you just don't write very much but
you aspire every damn day but what I
realized is I had this arbitrary list of
rules I asked to have my cup of coffee
and I have to have my notepad and the
correct pin I need the red pen and the
black pen and then I need the
appropriate writing program but then I
also keep a separate notepad on the
computer in a different program and all
of these things needed to happen and
then all crap I forgot need to do the
laundry and that needs to be done before
I can start writing and I and all of a
sudden I'd have 13 of my 15 items
checked off the list and I have no more
time left for writing and what I found
now is I have far far fewer rules I I
now I have one rule to start writing I
have to wake up that's my rule I said to
get out I write in my sleep yet but if I
do then I'll know rules and my point is
that's the only rule I have now it
doesn't matter what the you know I don't
care what what a computer program
Stephen King wrote to you used to write
a hit look what you care about is the
actual the doing itself one of my
favorite musicians David Gray I'm sure
many of you know him his 2000 album is
called white ladder and he works in a
beautiful studio he bought like a really
gorgeous studio in London
but that album the one that is a
record-breaking smash hit was recorded
in his bedroom and the point behind that
was sometimes you can capture the
special thing that you lose when you
don't have those same limitations so
what I would encourage you to do is
possibly set up some of those
limitations on yourself it doesn't mean
you have to instantly get rid of the
stuff but this is exactly what Ryan did
with the packing party it was a forced
limitation he didn't throw all the stuff
out hidden and rent a dumpster and chuck
his stuff in it what he did was just box
it all up for a period of time and then
brought back into his life the things he
was certain he needed to to live that
life and that thing that can be true
with hobbies or passions or anything
else I don't need to prove yourself with
those things long term but that short
term deprivation might help you
understand what actually does that value
to your life and what is an imaginary
value for your life I don't really have
a lot to add to that that was really
good but what I will give you a
limitation that I have and you can
interpret this however you want but I
typically look at stuff if I haven't
used it in the last 90 days and I'm not
going to use it in the next 90 days like
I'm honest with myself then I will
typically get rid of it now there are
some exceptional things like my
snowboard you know I'm not going to like
go snowboarding in September or April
actually you could play your
snowboarding in april of montana
actually i did earlier this month but
anyway forget that but what I'm saying
is it might be an exceptional thing
where I know I'm going to use it maybe
yours is a year maybe you look at it at
the circuit boards and those cables and
all those computer chips and my using
this jargon right
so like maybe look at that stuff and
you're like when's the last time have I
had that I've had after like you know
the last four years okay okay I'm not
going to use that in the next four years
or am I going to use that in the next
year whatever that rule is like just
make those rules and stick to it so I
don't know if that helps you out or not
man but also limiting like how many
number of things you can hold on to
because I mean really eat it build an
infinite amount of computers but the
question is how many you're going to
build over the next you know years so
okay I'm going to I'm going to have
enough parts to build two computers a
year whatever it may be again like just
trying to set those rules to help you
curate what what you have that's great
and not only is that I'll drip great
advice from both you but like what I
love is getting out of my own head
because I asked this question and and
you're giving me the answer and I'm
realizing that I'm actually on the way
to doing this like I am recording in the
camper with just the bare minimum but
what will fit in the camper and so like
I'm kind of I'm already on that path and
it's like makes me realize that okay I'm
doing well and just keep doing I just
keep doing it and yeah absolutely listed
and you know what I'm not trying to be
all doom and gloom here but there's not
an end to a man like you're always going
to have to be asking these questions I'm
always going to have to be sticking to
these boundaries and sometimes the
boundaries will change and that's okay I
hope that's not an end yeah I want to
keep y'all yeah yeah so and that's in
that is kind of the beautiful things
like there it's like you look at horizon
you ad towards it and then once you get
to that horizon there's another horizon
ahead of you yeah great thank you guys
daddy hi my name is Sophie and I'm
guessing I probably should have read one
of the books in addition to y0 every
work sorry you can ask you a question
then during like now I'm hearing the
whole box it up hold on to it and then
get rid of a theory that's not what we
did and so a couple weeks ago my mister
and I watch your documentary and we were
like whoa this is awesome and so it
started like a week of like let's get
rid of all this crap like God the drill
people
I'm glad you didn't wait to read a book
to start getting better I figured you
covered it in the movie that's what
everybody else does so but but so then I
forgot we were going on vacation first
vacation in forever and we went to Miami
and so I packed everything I had left
that was kind of remotely acceptable for
80 degree weather into a suitcase that
I've actively gotten drunk in and sit in
and just hoped it was under the weight
limit so he didn't have to pay like the
extra baggage charge I don't really know
what was in there it was a lot of stuff
and so we get down there and we're in
like actively like Miami South Beach
where like where the people are bowling
alleys in their house are or people who
like bedazzle their eyebrows like we saw
so much oh yes we took a we like where
we were on this cruise we saw Mark
Cuban's yacht which apparently is like a
300 million dollar yacht but it had like
four baby yacht so this it was like
reproducing
like around it and so like I guess my
question is not just to get up here and
like tell you all the things I like
totally messed up your well made million
yes that's a good start you can't live
on it but it is really fun when you
start on the baby yacht but like when I
was down there I remember like he'd
fallen asleep he just had pizza
delivered to us in beach chairs in South
Beach because apparently that's what
happens and I was just sitting there in
the only bathing suit I've left myself
feeling like a very very very white just
like you know like just like a little
pot-bellied pig looking around at all
these people with be dazzled eyebrows
and bowling alleys in their house and
like what do you do when you feel like
when you're like solid committed
minimalist but you recognize in certain
moments that you're still in a seriously
consumer driven environment you get kind
of bummed out because it is kind of
competitive and like that's kind of like
all around you all the time I guess is
what I'm asking so is it just because
I'm a beginner is it just because I kind
of suck it this bill will those moments
go away where where I'm like no I do
need that blue mascara like like I may
only wear a once but that one time will
be great
the short answer to your question is yes
and no and and so I'll try to try to
make that look a you test your blue
mascara now I mean the truth is that
will it get easier yeah in time any
habit that you be it's like when you go
to the gym for the first time and you
work out really really really hard and
all of a sudden you're sore as hell for
the next week like that's not a good
feeling either right and I think the
same thing can sometimes happen with
minimalism like you can get someone
who's who's just gung-ho really excited
and all of a sudden though I let's get
rid of everything and I think it's great
because personally I've never I've never
regretted anything that I've ever gotten
rid of but the truth is that I also
realized if I went this I mean I said
earlier it took me eight months to pare
down my life I wish I would have done it
sooner because I feel like I kind of
wasted a bit of time doing it but just
because it does get easier over time it
doesn't mean you always absolutely love
it you know I do exercise every single
day whether it's going to the gym or
physical therapy or yoga and I don't
always feel so inspired by it right now
like I'm really inspired to go to yoga
there but that's when I know I need I
need to go the most same thing with with
meditating or anything else and so I
think ultimately when it comes to to any
of that stuff when I see the the
consumerism and the world around us
whether it's at a shopping mall or on
South Beach we were just there last year
we had a tour stop there and I mean it's
will often speak in the most
unconventional places we a few years ago
spoken in the largest mall in North
America and West Edmonton Canada
and and it's much better to speak there
than at a Buddhist monastery right
because I mean what am I going to do you
guys have too many sandals no I'd rather
put our message up against the message
of consumerism but even even then of
course I'm going to be tempted by it
there are marketers and demographers who
make a quarter million half a million
dollars a year to aggregate my eyeballs
effectively to their product or service
and so yes it's always going to be
tempting but if you build up the sort of
mental musculature over time it will
become easier yeah it's funny I think
about the 300 million dollar yacht with
its baby yachts and there's soap hmm I
mean even having a boat I love to
wakeboard like I haven't gone in forever
since I lived like back in Ohio about
five years ago I guess it's going on but
I've like thought about like maybe one
day I get like just you know used like
old wakeboarding boat so I'm not even
thinking about yacht I'm just thinking
about like a wakeboarding bow but
thinking about having that makes me
think about my dad and he had just like
this really kind of little dinghy for
all intents and purposes and it was such
a pain in the neck like to upkeep
he's always say boat stands for bring
out another thousand because he's
constantly making repairs to it and then
like when we would go on boat trips like
he was he was I don't wanna say he was
never happy but like it was you know 50%
happiness and then 50% like you know
telling me to leave him alone and you
trying to maneuver the boat and you know
I'm like giving him wrong directions and
he's like back in the boat and whatever
like it was it was 50 percent good
experience 50 percent like not a very
pleasurable experience three hundred
million dollar yacht is going to cost
you millions of dollars of upkeep every
single year like you can't even you
can't upkeep that yourself so you know
for me when I look at even when we were
in South Beach and driving by and
looking at the houses like I would think
to myself how many dining rooms do those
houses have like maybe they had three
dining rooms are four dining rooms you
got to eat really fast the eatin for
dining room
I mean it to me the excess it is it is
depressing in a way because it does kind
of perpetuate itself but I think we are
starting to just get on the cusp of
where and you all being here is is kind
of proving this point of we are getting
on this cusp of realizing I guarantee
you if I dropped a 300 million dollar
yacht in your lap right now please don I
mean or anyone out there who thinks that
they want that they might be happy for a
day or a year like it there might be
some ephemeral happiness but that's just
it it's ephemeral and you know the rich
people I meet who maybe they have a lot
of really night maybe they're not
minimalist and they have a lot of really
nice stuff if they're happy it's because
they're happy with who they are they're
happy with the relationships they have
in their life they don't need all that
stuff and the money to be happy they're
just happy people like you probably take
all that stuff away and they would just
find another way to make money because
they would just still go go through life
being happy and doing what they needed
to do to to continue that that
meaningful life and I keep saying happy
but you know I don't think happiness is
the point anymore when I was when I was
in the corporate world I would always
like chase that happiness and I would
argue that I would get the happiness so
when I got that new car every two years
I just remember like every two years
like I'd get a new car and it was like
oh yeah his cars awesome but then I'd
get that you know first car payment and
then that second car payment and then it
just it was that happiness depreciated
so every time I got happiness it was
like it was just had it and then it was
just kind of fleeting and now instead of
focusing on happiness I focus on living
a meaningful life
and to me what that means is my short
term actions aligning with my long term
values and beliefs in the beautiful
thing about pursuing a meaningful life
is happiness is this beautiful
by-product that happens so if yes if you
keep it up it will absolutely get easier
there's no doubt about it but you know
what I'm going to give you permission to
go get blue mascara after the show go
get it go get your blue mascara I guess
that lets not I mean let's not be
dramatic like I'm not going not an
animal Jessica Williams back there Jess
oh there you are would you mind grabbing
me a copy of essential thank you so so
you didn't do your pre work no no I'm
always honest so I was a kid who said I
didn't do my homework I'm going to fake
it guys appreciate your honesty um but
I'm going to give you I don't look like
I'm selling you one of our books because
that's not what I'm here to do by the
way they're for sale back there yeah but
to be fair the profits go to our
favorite charity
it's the Josh and Ryan gas wanting to
get back to Missoula but I'd love to
everyone
ladies and gentlemen Jessica Williams if
you follow us on like Twitter or
Instagram or Facebook or what else do
the kids do these days you yak I have no
idea - do you follow us on Yik yak then
it's just that that manages all of that
and she does such a phenomenal job just
thank you so much for being here I
really appreciate it
I want to give you that book because
there are some rules in there there's a
whole chapter on stuff and and some
basic rules it really is we were at
three different books and there's
everything that remains which is my
favorite thing that I've ever written
it's a memoir about the five years of
Ryan and I'm moving from the student
type corporate guys to minimalist that's
where the y2 book we wrote a book called
minimalism living meaningful life that's
sort of the what - book like what are
the values in your life and this is the
more of a how-to book it's called
essential it's an essay collection 150
different essays but in there is
something called the 20/20 rule and your
blue mascara fits into that possibly and
what you I mentioned when I was talking
earlier the three most dangerous words
in the English language just in case I
held on to so many things just in case
justify I use that as justification to
have hoards of stuff in my basement
attic calls its garage storage facility
just in case I might need it and the
truth is that I didn't need the vast
majority of those so I like I gave
myself permission let goes just the case
because I realized I could replace any
of those just in case items for less
than twenty dollars in less than 20
minutes we call it the 20/20 rule now
you might say that's a rule of privilege
I don't want to have to spend $20.00
every single day on some just in case
item you'd have a good point if that was
true but I can tell you that with the
last five years since Ryan and I have
implemented that rule we've used it five
times between the two of us and that
rule has given me permission to let go
of tens of thousands of other just
incase items that I wasn't getting any
other value from at all so this is like
minimalism for dummies no no but you
should write that book
I have other passions that end in boards
that I'm focusing on right now I'm not a
writer bad awesome thank you I really do
guys like to watch you hey Ryan you know
time it is oh yeah you know what time it
is
it's time for our hashtag ask the
minimalist lightning round we are on
what is a twitter and instagram at the
minimalists and facebook.com slash the
minimalist and we usually answer
questions from there right now people
tweet us and and in stuff out of verb
yet anyway but y'all are here so if you
want to give us a a question we will try
to respond with a short shareable less
than 140 character response and I guess
when Shawn when you actually post this
up sometime
he'll put the our responses in the show
notes by the way for people listening at
home if you have a comment or tip for
anyone today you can you can leave us a
voice now four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine we will air our
favorite comments and tips on the next
episode you can also send a voice in
them all right from your phone to
podcast at the minimalists comm and we
will air those comments and tips real
soon okay what's your name I'm Miranda
and thank you guys for coming to
Portland I hope we're showing you a good
time blue mascara is a tough act to
follow
so I have a parenting question so Josh I
guess this is kind of aimed at you and I
have three kids I'm interested to know
we're kind of three kids no I have two
oh and I'm interested to know your
answer and you wrote everything that
remains as a single childless bachelor
and you now find yourself in a very
different position you have for all
intents and purposes a spouse in a child
does minimalism look different to you
now as a parent is it harder than you
thought it would be or is it
have you just continued the same
paradigm
adding these people to your life let me
take you to my hundred and forty
characters right now I'm going to count
everywhere please do we get we got to
keep it honest minimalism is more
challenging as a family but that's why
it's more important by the way you all
are the judge there so that applause was
sort of a meter so Ryan Faran all her
kids
that's tweetable let me think for a
second
I'm gonna pass you get that one going
beautiful hi guys I'm Kate so glad you
guys are here Audrey here thanks I've
been following you for quite a while as
you guys kind of alluded to Twitter
Instagram TED Talks the documentary what
is your favorite part like if you could
only do one of them what's your favorite
part of this journey are on
you wanna go first okay all right all
right by the way we just turned this
into a game like two shows ago and ever
since we've done that leg it's it's so
much pressure now well usually what
happens like much fun and then James
gamified it we usually hit like a day
don't you type something out and make it
you know turn some platitude into
something meaningful but now you're just
going to be stuck with some quick
bromide all right the question now I
have stumped the minimalists I love it
what's your favorite part of it oh yeah
okay very good so I'll give you the
honest answer after I give you my
tweetable answer as my life changes that
which adds value changes as well that's
that's my pity share of wine sir and
it's true but but of if I had to pick
one thing it would be writing narrative
nonfiction for sure um and I think I
would uh yeah
I would say I this is a suitable answer
it ain't that awesome but also there
nothing makes me happier than living a
well curated life so I'm just going to
expound a little bit there isn't a
favorite part maybe actually I'm going
to redo this there isn't a favorite part
of minimalism yeah there's nothing makes
me happier than living a well curated
life I mean it's it's all great
I saw it you definitely get that guys
thanks for all you do
alright guys you mentioned Buddhism
earlier ironically and do you guys feel
any weird kinship with monks or priests
and thousand poverty and asceticism or
do you guys feel any of that do you feel
like you can connect with that idea do
you feel closer to God so I got 140
characters for this one
go forth it doesn't matter what
organized religion you belong to or what
God you worship they all want you to
live a simple life you mentioned
asceticism which those of you who don't
want asceticism is it's perpetual
suffering - yeah I'm doing a bad job of
making a tweetable but is dealing with
pain with pain basically and so my
tweetable answer would be that
minimalism is not about deprivation
minimalism is about aligning your
short-term actions with your long-term
values
also Ryan and I have different religious
and spiritual beliefs so I can attest
that it really doesn't matter what your
what's your beliefs that's why we never
really talk about it we would just be
arguing all the time hey my name is Alex
I got a relatively objective one for you
what book are you reading right now okay
or what book are you reading right now
maybe though are minimalist allowed to
read more than one book at a time yeah I
actually want to talk about the book I
just finished but I can't really tweet
that I guess what it's cool we can just
talk well books are written right now go
for okay
oh actually there were six people online
so we'll just talk about this right okay
I just got done reading a book by
Christopher Ryan and I can never
remember his co-authors name I'm so
sorry of she's listening to this right
now but it's called sex at dawn and it's
a it's kind of a old book like I want to
say four or five years old but it does
an amazing job of talking about how sex
is evolved essentially through our
civilization and the biggest point I got
from it which has nothing to do the sex
but the biggest point I got from it was
um
when I think about a man trying not to
get like political when I think about
certain things in life I'll just say
that and I look at it going backwards I
guess it's like I look at it as a D
evolution as it devolving and this book
talks about how evolution is not about
it's not about going forwards or
backwards it's simply survival
and for me I don't know why but like
that one point like really really helped
me to feel okay with the way the world
is because you know that's saying like
sometimes that to get worse to get
better I mean that that is evolution
essentially an evolution is about
survival but if anyone is I don't know
like if that sounds like it would take
anyone pictures
it just it's really cool to use a lot of
just examples of you know how sex is
viewed in different parts of the world
how it was viewed in the past why it is
viewed the way it is now why our society
looks at it the way it is and it's a
real big eye-opener and it's not late
and it's not an eye-opener in the sense
of like I you know I'm changing my
morals or you know hasn't shifted my
moral compass but it's just interesting
to see like why we're at where we're at
today
yeah I agree it's a great book we're
also if we're going to be on his podcast
next week we'll be out in LA doing some
stuff and he has a great podcast called
tangentially speaking and he's just he's
a brilliant guy and he interviews really
interesting people I about there's only
one book that I go back was people can
go back to regularly but there's one
that I tend to go back to quite a bit
especially when were preparing for tour
it's
epictetus is discourses and so I've been
reading that recently so for those of
you who are familiar I actually think
that the woman right before you
mentioned maybe the stoicism or I mean
she mentioned aesthetics which is not
unsimilar but he's one of the Stoics so
a couple thousand years old a lot of
great traditional wisdom and in the
discourses he's my favorite of the
Stoics and also I my partner and I we
read to each other at night because she
is really actually I read aloud to her
because she has trouble getting to sleep
and so I want to help her be able to go
to sleep so
where we like to read fiction at night I
can't remember
oh yes I can I don't recommend this book
to anyone but I love it in soda City but
you have to have a really twisted sense
of humor to get into it so just the
caveat it's called the average American
male by Chad Culkin and yeah it's like
it's nc-17 for sure but not because well
yeah because of that too but but yeah
it's it's vulgar
it's like if you could if you could get
into well if you were to take a
testosterone still 20 something year old
male and projected it onto the pages of
a main character of a book and all of
his thoughts were just spilling onto the
page it would sort of be like that so I
don't know if that's helpful at all
thank you thank you thanks all right
we're back to the lightning round all
right hi guys
thank you for coming out to Portland I
have a career question actually from my
wonderful fiancee in the back when you
have kind of two career paths ahead of
you that would both bring value to your
life but kind of in different ways how
do you figure out which direction would
kind of work with your life let me see
if I can II I'm going to I'm going to
talk about I'm going to work this out
aloud and then I'll try to make it
tweetable and might be a better strategy
going forward sometimes there's a right
path and a left path sometimes with the
right path that are wrong paths and
sometimes there's a right path and no
other path and you need to figure out
which one that you're trying to go down
and so for you
there is a right path and a wrong path
take the right path if there is a right
path and a left path then pick a path
and go I get sweet Abel
[Music]
the best recipe for discontent is being
stuck in a career that doesn't align
with your long-term values and beliefs
so I'm just going to expound them out a
little bit you said that both of them
kind of align with the values and
beliefs but one of them does align more
so first get clear on what the values
and beliefs are because that's so
important I mean that is fundamental if
anyone is in here is like I want to
start this minimalist journey like start
with that question of you know how my
your life be better with less then get
to your values and beliefs because
that's really what I feel like people
should be working towards and it was
aren't written down then it's very hard
to have a compass I've gone through this
exercise that's awesome but you've got
to ask yourself like okay is job a going
to require me to be away from home or
its job B oh no job he's going to like
allow me to be home at dinner for five
o'clock I mean it's it's going to be the
small fit right now seems small but in
the future it's going to add up to a lot
so I I doubt that they're both exactly
aligned with the values and beliefs
there's going to be one that is going to
stand out more than the other for sure
I've got a pity thing for you
suffering lies at the precipice of
indecision thanks for the question
thank you yeah so besides your
opportunity to spread your message again
here in Portland Maine what about your
experience this time has added value for
you
brian has two words for you burger bar I
solved it over there is that a pretty
awesome place yeah Oh al coholic magic I
know I know that this is this a
tiebreaker
are we are we still game of fighting I
don't know it's just feels like a
tiebreaker
all right Maine Portland Maine let me
let me Portland Maine has the best
lobster roll I've ever had in my life
that would be disappointing if we didn't
[Music]
go one so screams oh you always say
a delayed laugh over it the chef what is
the added value to my life from Portland
we just got in here man it's just really
unfortunate oh it's definitely the best
weather of the tour but I don't have a
pity thing but I will tell you that it
it to me it really does feel like a very
big small town and I like that you know
I I find as we travel around the country
many of my favorite cities are our towns
that are large enough to have a lot of
culture but not large enough to sustain
a major league football team or baseball
team on their own you know we grew up in
Dayton Ohio and you know there's there's
no no sports there and and with my
favorite cities like Tucson or Salt Lake
City or Portland Maine or Missoula
Montana or st. Petersburg Florida and I
find that when we go to these places
because they're not incredibly large
there seems to be a lot of here we go I
told you I'd get there
Portland Maine has a [ __ ] ton of culture
per capita he also got screams thanks
for the question and you can just set
that microphone up you want to have it
so thank you all right show before we
wrap up to a few other people I want to
thank first off I want to is as Malik
anywhere around here so there he is
Sean mihalick he is a very talented
novelist he works with his works was for
a while we actually met him in our very
first tour in Pittsburgh back in 2011
and since then he's been out in Montana
with us and he's got a great job but if
you get a chance to read any fiction
anytime soon Sean the Halleck look him
up but he's been helping us out he'll be
in the back as well we have some books
back there in about 15 or 20 minutes
we'll be back there as well we tend to
do a hug line there totally optional
by the way but they are free and
transferable so you can pick one up if
you'd like we also have books back there
and we'll do pictures and all that fun
stuff as well so let's give Sean a round
of applause thanks for being with us
brother
and what about the venue port city music
hall thank you so much for having us
tonight yeah thank you so much most
important I want to thank you I want to
thank you for I know cost some money to
get into this because we have to pay for
the space we have to pay to travel here
but it really costs more than that it
cost your time and your attention and
we're really grateful that you're
willing to give up a few hours of your
time tonight and give us your time and
your attention those are your two most
precious resources and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works we'll see you soon
[Applause]
hey you real quick before we get into
those comments and tips from our
listeners a couple things that are going
on right here right now in the lives of
the minimalists I already talked about
at the beginning of the podcast we were
on the road 40 different cities les is
now calm you can find the city closest
to you but also Ryan and I are in the
middle of building a podcast and film
studio and we could use your help we
refuse to clutter our podcasts with
advertisements so we rely on people like
you to help us create something
meaningful so if you want to see more
meaningful audio and video creations
this year you can help us out you can be
part of the 1% of our audience who is
supporting our work just go to the
minimalists com you can click on donate
it at the top you can either contribute
one time the PayPal or if you really
want to create something sustainable you
can do the patreon account so we have a
patreon account allows you to support us
on a per episode basis you don't have to
support anyone else and you can also cap
that so Ryan and I go crazy and we start
putting out 20 podcast episodes a month
you don't have to contribute to every
episode we really appreciate your
support on that if you can't afford to
support us monetarily don't worry we
also have other ways to support us so
you can go over to iTunes and leave us a
review obviously we prefer a 5 star
review but
hate our guts you can leave a one-star
review we'll be okay with that as well
but this month may 2017 for every review
that someone leaves will donate ten
dollars in your name to the against
malaria foundation we're trying to save
some lives it takes about thirty five
hundred dollars to save one life so for
every three hundred and fifty reviews we
get this month together we can save one
life did you know that half the people
who have ever lived have died from
malaria and we can help change that we
can do a little bit to help a few people
in the world so if you'd be willing to
just take 60 seconds pause the podcast
and leave a review on iTunes we would
greatly appreciate it
alright y'all enjoy these comments and
tips from our listeners hey Josh and
Ryan solution from Australia just wring
in because I was listening to your
Pittsburgh podcast and there was a woman
there was asking question about what to
do with her blanket that and had given
to her and it was covered with like
photos of her as like growing up and as
a child and she does not want to keep it
and I had a suggestion that she could
donate it to an animal shelter any
blankets or you know old sheets or
towels or bedding and stuff that people
want to get rid of in in their mincing
journey animal shelters are a great
option because obviously the animals not
going to care if there's a warm blanket
with the picture of your face on it um
they're just going to be grateful that
they have something warm to snuggle up
into and have a nice safe sleep so don't
forget the animals and that's always an
option hi my name is Laurie
I am from Raleigh North Carolina and
listening to your podcast for quite a
while now I was listening to one
recently where
a young woman had called in asking the
question and her husband were trying to
pay down some debt and she had just been
laid off they were a young family it
seemed and she had decided that she
would stay home the advice that was
given was in order for her to better pay
down her debt was for her to get a job
and while I understand the ramifications
to that my concern is that I believe you
guys may have missed the mark on that
the reasoning behind parents staying
home a lot of times and I know this from
experience I'm just being from my
experience is the stages at which your
parent they are meeting in their short
and a lot of times when people choose to
stay home they choose to stay home so
they could be with their children during
those stages usually the baby stage and
the younger stages sometimes older
stages but you know once that stage is
gone you can never get it back
so for me staying home is well it's a
financial decision it's also something
that's bringing value to my life
[Music]
everything you think that's me every
little thing you imagine me every little
thing that's feeding your greed oh I
bear that you find out every little
thing that you got hey every little
thing that you like you gotta reach for
me
you got a grin oh I bet you'd be fine
without me
hey hey
[Music]
Oh